okay so everyone the first speaker of
today is low tech and he's gonna talk
about and it was always great to be back
at Cal Berkeley character too so thank
you very much take care for the
invitation so I talked about yes so it's
work that involved many people and
there's three pieces I may have to stop
at the end of the second piece which is
fine so I've mentioned more of these
collaborators in each piece so this is a
system that we look at where the Tristan
come from they are in the u.s. about 10
to 20 thousand large centralized
generation plants that generates the
majority of electricity then it goes
through a power network eventually get
to residential houses commercial houses
and so on which will be the plug on the
wall
the difference between transmission
network and this vision network is that
transmission network is much longer
distance and not a much high voltages so
this will be hundreds of thousands of
votes distribution network is low
voltage eventually you step down to 120
volt here here in particular example
15,000 so it's lower he steps up to a
transmission network because at high
voltage the network loss is to lower the
key difference is that transmission
network is typically mesh net with loose
worth in distribution network almost all
distributes to network with exceptions
are tree topology so that turns out to
be important as we see later on so both
the system dynamics and the controller
we apply it spends a large range of time
scale from years where do a lot of
planning to their head which we run
their head market for example two hours
and say 15 or 5 minutes so real time in
electricity market typically means 5
minutes and
- under minutes two seconds even sub
seconds and the behavior of the network
at different time scales certainly is
different and they're described by
different models so for the time scales
here that we will talk about this will
be the powerful equations and in a third
part if we do get to that then is sort
of a seconds time scale then you have
all these and depending on how realistic
you want to be say for generate a model
for example you have different
complexity of models so we'll talk about
the first and the second power will be
here and then further power will be here
and opf which is the problems that
describes a lot of applications here
you're simply a constrained optimization
it is important because in many of those
power system operations and planning
problems underlying those application is
this OPF and therefore it is routinely
being solved for never control
optimization decisions and also to set
pricing for example at timescales
minutes hours days and so on is first
one majoring in sixty two wanting to be
non Congress because the kerkhof law is
is nonlinear if you look at what's the
most widely used algorithm is actually
linearization so you linearize your
non-linear power flow equations and then
you get an LP you solve it then a
solution may not satisfy the powerful
equations and therefore you may not be
able to apply them in practice what you
do then is where the engineering
intuition comes in you treat your LP and
then you repeat the cycle but there are
many many options that people have
applied to to appear properly so the
non-linearity of public questions give
us non convex problem and you can
visualize how terrible it could be so
this is a very simple example with three
buses three nodes on the network and we
project to some verbose in your
optimization then this is the feasible
set
so in this particular example there are
three nodes each has a certain power
plan so this is yeah and then lines
connecting them so I will do it with non
convexity and poverty question is to one
source of non convexity there are other
sources such as you have to deal with
discrete variables but here I'm only
talking about non convexity due to
powerful equations so this is a non
convexity that we cannot design a way so
if two approaches and many others one in
semi-definite realization I will talk
about and the second idea separately the
second idea is using degree as the
implicit power flow solution solvers so
this is online so the first right so the
first part is some exact formulation the
word that has been going on for the last
few years and then the second part so it
defines the model I'll just give you a
sense of where the computational
challenges and some of some of the
results but you mainly serves as a
motivation for the second part which is
on PF so both are slower time scale
problems and then if we have time we can
extend the idea here to a fast time
scale problem which is low sigh
frequency control alright so the first
part many people have contributed to
this and here some of them both used to
be a graduate student kara professor
many trendy for reviving also a graduate
student at Caltech lingua was a graduate
student at and Java lover here
I was John Paul student all right so the
problem again is you want to minimize a
certain cause examples of that subject a
tool to say okay right okay let me just
write so it be the mathematical forget
do certain constraints basically and so
the variable is the Comcast voltage face
at each node in the network so VI is a
complex number
and see the cost matrices ins compress
and then YJ depends on the network so YJ
describes the network
he gives both the network topology but
also impedance on the lines and this
typically we'll assume this is positive
definite and therefore the objective
function is simple all the complexity in
this particular simple formulation is in
this powerful equation so YJ are 1 for
each node J is macrame is not even
information it's not not PSD and
powerful equation describes that at each
node j SJ is a complex number that
represents the real power and reactive
power imaginary power at node J so this
could be I say J has a generator that
you generates real power and imagining
power so I can think of an account in
the phasor domain each power has two
components and you can map it to
physical meanings but each Power Plus is
a generous generator node then it
generates the real and reactive power
the Comcast pair number must equal to
this and this simply represents klokov
law and you says every node J power must
be balanced that's all he says but it's
quadratic in the variable V that's the
important piece so so why J 1 for H J is
a n by n matrix and this is R and 1
matrix so this is the N by n matrix you
take the trace the sum of diagonal terms
which because this is not a mission is a
complex number this must equal to the
power ingestion at node J if J is a load
then this is basically the tip you take
negative values for real and reactive
reimagine parts so the quality you just
have the Equality so as J you if you
think of this as a generator then this
inequality simply says the generator has
a certain capacity
lower bound which could be 0 and some
final problem and then this constraint
says that the voltage magnitude must be
within say five percent of its nominal
value so 120 volt here plus or minus
five percent so that's the base
structure of OPM it's now conversed
again because this is non-count less and
therefore you've got a QC q p a said way
to deal with this is to do SDP
organization so it looks like this this
is the problem we have this is the OPF
and this is where the non-combative is
this is often done converse but it is
the same form you can write this one in
the same room here and the thing to note
is that everywhere the verbal v appears
the appears deviate of my matrix and
therefore you can think of these majors
as a verbal and write an equivalent
problem just replace VV h by the matrix
w so this is empire in from cast matrix
except that it's not arbitrary and by a
matrix matrix has to be process mi
definite and rm1 but the important thing
to note is that what this is quadratic
in V this is linear in verbal so clerk
of law is linear in this matrix P and
this is convex constraint and this is
the only non convex constraint and see
as the PCB says let's ignore okay
so and therefore if you look at the
feasts of the two problems equivalent in
a sense that there's a one-to-one
mapping between the feasts process even
me you can write aww test that by these
other conditions and given a W test
about these certain conditions there's a
unique video about this set of
conditions up to a rotation and
therefore you can cut rise the feasible
set which are for the OPF by this set in
W right and this is not mean our
capacity if we ignore this and therefore
you minimize your cost not over this set
but over deserve without Ram 1 then you
get a Congress problem is as the key you
solve optimal solution and then you
check what the optimal solution W star
turns out to be DRAM 1 if this Ram 1
then you can obtain an optimal V for
your regional Commerce Park
so this is great except that this source
for n marble and comcast marbles and
this is n square so we would like to be
able to reduce that and here's one idea
so this is STP if you have a network of
five notes then we solve for five by
five complex matrix but if we look at if
you look at the kerkhof law right so
curve law says this phrase equals some
SJ if you expand this then you see that
this is non zero only at off diagonal
entries when that's a 1/3 when there's a
link between one note one in those three
if there's no link between I and J then
then this expression doesn't depend on
WI J and therefore you can think of
what's got a partial matrix simply is
simply a set of complex numbers that
corresponds to the the entries for which
you do have a link closet diagonals and
therefore the number of verbals here in
the partial matrix is not n square by n
plus 2 m and for typical network M is
much less than n square so for algebra
test system benchmark system for example
M is more no more than 1.6 n for example
so it's something linear and therefore
for last network gives it's much much
smaller problem these graphs
surprisingly not necessarily it's not
clear high
one reason is perhaps the oh he's like
whatever leaves saying there's a
physical network a physical system and
there's a model the actual model the
people use even for actually tech
benchmark system is typically they are
they they they are transformed so you
take a physical network and modulate and
then you you get you get a messy graph
and then you do some transformation get
a simpler one perhaps during that
transformation you get this
all right so okay so so how do we
describe the how do we how do we so how
do we describe the feasible set opf in
terms of the partial matrix WG so that
is what we do it for STP is we establish
a one-to-one mapping between V and and
by matrice so that they survive the
quota equations these are linear
equations but then we require this so if
you want to describe the in terms of the
partial matrix you not only replace W by
WT which is the partial matrix but also
the the simplest comes here you don't
require the entire W to be positive
semi-definite in Graham 1 but only for
every line that connects no J and K you
have this 2 by 2 matrix so WJ WJ k WK j
WJ j so 2 by 2 matrix
you need five those 2 by 2 matrices with
PSD and r m1 so you have as many as
number of lines but each is much smaller
piece but then you require your cycle
condition there's some condition on on
this WT the set of Comcast numbers like
the cycle condition the only thing I
want to point out is that if you look at
these two conditions these are the
conditions are local in a sense that
each equation involves verbals at two
ends of a line same here but this is
global the cycle condition is global it
depends in verbals or the entire cycle
and that has dark intensity and then you
can show that indeed all three sets are
you equivalent in the sense your sir I
want to a mapping among all right and
therefore given any partial matrix
there's only one way you can feel that
you think you can complete the matrix up
up to a rotation and then you can map it
to the voltage
okay and therefore we could use our
minimizing cost of what this said we can
minimize the cost over this set and then
once we get an optimal solution we can
check the condition we can check whether
each 2x2 matrix is psi and ram1 and also
say if I cycle condition if it does that
we can obtain a global optimal solution
otherwise we're stuck except that this
is also non convex but if you look at
where the convexity comes in is worth of
ram 1 this is 2 by 3 2 by 2 matrices in
no cycle condition so the natural thing
to do is just ignore them then you can
SOC P much simpler what does a magnitude
faster typically for large networks ok
and therefore right and if the network
turns out to have tree topology radio
network means is a tree topology then as
the period station and SOC P will be the
same same tightness if master will be
strictly SDP Illustrated tiger okay and
therefore for recorder almost all
distribution systems which are probably
where most of the smart innovations will
first appear on radio our tree topology
and therefore for them never self SDPs
office with CP in different strategy is
in zero solving opf you solve the
recession and then with an optimal
solution of the recession you check some
conditions even a satisfied a you are
done
so and therefore it is important that we
can do this and we'll get a optimal
solution densified conditions of course
there's no guarantee except that if the
network is a tree then people have
developed sufficient conditions that
will guarantee this strategy will work
now empirically empirically meaning that
people try many actually test systems
and some data from utility companies and
so on
very often you will get optimal
solutions even when the sufficient
conditions are not satisfied so somehow
practical network seems to have nice
structure ok so here's one class of
conditions sufficient conditions there
that will guarantee a so CP realization
we always be exact network
so in general we have this QT QP + o PF
is just one example that it is
characterized by the set of cost
matrices and constraint matrices and for
this example the the bounds
the biomatter there are other conditions
where the pounds are important so a key
condition is that you're the funny so
you look at the set of matrices take any
two nodes are connected so you have a I
J you're live between I and J so you get
k plus 1 Comcast numbers the magnitude
of these compares numbers are not
important you just care about the face
so you can plot them on this unit circle
in the complex plane if all those
numbers lies on a half plane any half
planes through through through the
origin so you draw a line through the
origin if you can find their line since
they're all those at k plus 1 complex
numbers slides on one side of the line
you could lie on the line then as the
superior station will be exact for what
tree network ok the implication so
that's what general qqp the implication
you map it to opf then he has something
to do with remember the OPF has this
constraint on the voltages and also on
say the injections so the generation
limits for example or the load limits
you are two in command response there's
a certain limit you can do your
optimization over so those limits so he
has so that condition has implications
on what those limits can be in terms of
the for this condition the voltage
limits do not matter is the the upper
lower bounds on on the generated limits
or low limits and then there are some
other conditions where the bounds on the
general degeneration low limits are now
important is only the upper bound on the
voltage so here's a pictorial
illustration where the in this
particular example the feasible set up
here with this black curve which is non
convex well you to SDP you you basically
get a combats roughly accomplished out
almost of this the purple region and if
2's OCP then you get this yellow region
which is strictly
streeted launcher and when when you just
accept what happened say in this
particular example is so this is a mesh
network but it turns out to be exact
he said the boundary of the purple
region STP feasible set coincide with
the old region did this back half the
original physical sense and therefore if
the cost function is cost the level sets
here then when you minimize over the
purple region SDP recitation you will
get an optimal point their lives on the
black curve and therefore you get an
optimal solution one for each node
Natyam it that's actually not the
emergence major but it depends on
animated images as a part about my
station variable right oh when you
define yes so the capacitor banks you
can do but then the capacitor banks will
be attached to the nose there are also
new technology palette Ron is where you
can change the line impedance that's
perhaps what you're referring to yes
then you can do that now if to the other
extreme if you if you assume there's
potentially a phase shifter that allows
you to change the face as I say
similarly perform Karissa's on every
line then the the the sufficient
condition that host only for the for the
radio will hope for the mesh as well and
now it turns out you don't need whoever
just will face you for every line the
network you can take any arbitrary
spanning tree on the network you can
optimize if whatever criterion
pick a spanning tree you only need no
more than a face ship at each line not
on the tree so internet or a spouse is
typically a small number but still
it's not practical yet it could be in
the future so no one's going to install
phase shifting you normally get a
compass opf now yes okay so the many
questions one can ask so you can clarify
different realizations that relationship
among them and did there are also
different powerful models and the
relation among them and then you can
look at under what conditions is that
what if the first order air searching is
no exact then you can go up the
polynomial my facial hierarchy and try
to tighten the recession at a course of
computational complexity
they're also nonlinear Teddy's reckon
you can apply you can look at many
applications on top of this so if you're
doing demand response
Evi charging or even economic dispatch
power power market market power analysis
and so on you can use are those kind of
questions you can also say let's assume
the resistance could be a certain to
solve complex problem then do we have a
easier way to come up with teach better
algorithms walk here and so on and then
you can apply you can extend the theory
to multi phase unbalanced networks and
so on
right so there certainly many things you
can post here that can potentially be
adopted for example I can do either
charging work with utility so what is
practical being a profit depends on
whatever technology is easy meaning that
it's reasonably cost we implement and so
on but a bigger hurdle is you have to
convince
first for let's say you wanted to either
charging but also try to up Co optimize
with the quiescent you need to work with
utility so that's usually the heart but
much harder part than the technical part
there are also economic dispatch right
now people use what's called easy OPF
simply you solve the LP the universe
Asian FERC and also what some some other
people is trying to push very hard to
have ISOs to use AC opf to solve the
economic dispatch so certainly there are
computational use technical challenges
in all of that but the much bigger
hurdle to overcome is actually to
convince the industries and all of that
so the the some people told me that
their expectation that you would take 10
years those those are non technical
hurdles so I think some of the
techniques but there's no great
technical barrier is the same thing if
you develop something that is you prove
a great theorem a divine new career
algorithm moving into practice can can
be much
how much benefit how much benefit right
so again that doesn't seem to be
consensus there are people who said
there won't be much difference there
people who believe there can be huge so
for estimate that if you just do
economic dispatch on AC OPF you can
press save between two to ten billion
per year is that big enough is free
money after development so it's not
clear it certainly depends Sharma price
I'm walking into yes okay so so what is
one of the major difficulty will see
that tricity network is that there's no
last care inexpensive queues energy
storage in a network endear for supply
demand is to balance every point every
time with the network unless you are
like Norway ninety percent hydro sorry
so then just I had a follow-up question
to that you have to continuously solve
the equation because demands are
changing pretty rapidly right so how do
you update your solutions right okay so
this is there's a long answer we can
take it offline but the quick answer is
that again it depends on application you
look at economic dispatch for example
tell you saw four four four four markers
that's off every 15 minutes and
therefore you you you lovely schedule
your generation now the small and then
you hope that is roughly balanced and
then the small thing then there are
other mechanisms that would deal with it
okay so the second part on IOT F so
again gun is used to be a quest where
Caltech PJ who
was a postdoc is that you're joining
Pierre now this week and J time from
classroom counter okay so the motivation
so if you look at the two biggest
networks a communication network and
they've had the communication that were
in the power Network both start to about
130 years ago in a very similar
engineering economic record structure to
provide a single commodity extremely
reliably and both went through great
developments through the walls post was
and everything even started to directly
around the nose not surprised me that
was a political time many things got the
idea regularly
traders are the same time so the
developments have been worse parallel
until about two decades ago when the
telephone network went through a
architectural transformation to become
to become the internet sorry
so that impacts huge you started from
engineering by changes the landscape of
multiple industries the hope is perhaps
power network will also add no bro a
similar architectural transformation in
the coming decades and therefore a lot
of things need to change again we can
discuss off offline but one thing that
we are interesting in is that instead of
right so right today if you look at a
power network there let's say in the
u.s. 10 to 20,000 small number of large
control points these are the generators
that we control there can be hundreds of
millions or maybe billion endpoints that
are just lows with roughly do not
control hovering the future the
situation is almost flipped that we have
hundreds of millions at distributed
energy resources which which are PV is
wind turbines electric vehicles energy
storage smart building smart appliances
and so on that are intelligent that can
be controlled they are not only there
are not just passive laws some may
generate some we communicate measure
computer control and all of them right
so that's the kind of network and that a
network we think a lot of the
applications in that kind of environment
we require real-time optimization
control and a lot of a computational
challenge and the lack one of the
computational challenges underlying them
is to explicitly your interest is so
powerfully through equations which we
saw it's difficult but the networks that
is solving that for us for free and
scale in real time and the idea is that
whatever you want to do perhaps we can
exploit that and if we do that then we
will naturally get algorithms that dare
to evolve in their work conditions so
that's the online the real-time partner
for the workshop so I wanted to give you
two examples one is on RPF quite fast
time scale but I don't think I would
have time for the third pass so we just
look at the online OPF okay so I will
also close with this slide so hopefully
at that time these become clearer what
this means
so from the first part which we saw that
instead of solving the second sub
realization which is okay fine good but
the traditional algorithm whether you
use it to solve this directly or solve
this directly or offline which means you
compute until converges then you apply
the solution and therefore it's not
suitable for our purpose but later on
I'll show you in some simulations that
will complete our online algorithm with
this offline algorithm so we'll compare
with you offline software a station you
chair you in diga optimal solution and
you compare the optimality and the
computation time for for the online of
it okay so the idea of all are very
simple so if you think about what we can
actually do well in a physical system
like the physical system there's a
there's a model like at whatever least
set in fits and hopefully every so what
is the model a model is simply self
verbals and set of equations hopefully
every verb row corresponds to some
controllable device or some stay in the
physical network the corn is in the
physical network we cannot control all
stages only a set of variables that we
can control and therefore so these are
the controllable device is X and the
uncontrollable never stays Y so now
we're looking at and therefore what we
can really the only thing we can do is
when we interrupt the physical network
we can only change eggs the network is
going to settle down in something for
their wise mathematically it means that
you solve the powerful equations to
obtain the y that's what it means
so the OPF you can write it in say you
want to minimize that and cost you
separately in X Y or it doesn't have to
be over these two variables subjected to
several constraints why are the powerful
equations that we saw we just think
you've some nonlinear equality the
second sub constraint is simply some
simple path constraint so this could be
say the voltage pounds or the generation
bounds and so on there's a simple path
constraints
that's like what I mentioned earlier is
simply the assumption that suppose the
Jacobian of power flow equations is not
it's non singular in appropriate regions
then given any control action takes the
network it's going to solve this for us
and give us a wild fix so that's the
idea and therefore you can write the
entire opf test in terms of X instead of
X of Y right then it looks like this so
typically this is simple convex this is
all the complexity is this is a simple
commands constraint but when you
eliminate Y you get a non typically non
convex objective function and then some
non convex constraint so you can
eliminate this one way you don't have to
put one approach you can eliminate this
by just put this two up to the objective
function as a pair through a barrier
function right then you get a
complicated objective function as a
function weights traumatise up by your
area function over a street beside that
is extremely simple supposing they are
solving this problem solve this problem
and again the basic strategy is very
simple where you we can only when we
interact with the physical system we can
only control the control variables so
iteratively we compute the controllable
verbos as let's say one gradient step
apply to the network and then let's
assume you can measure everything you
measure all the works isn't physical
never is going to compute solve the
power equation give us their wild let's
assume we can measure every Y and
communicate and compute the next
gradient centrally there's a whole set
of issues that in practice you cannot
measure every why you may have
communication problems
you may have a do in a digital manner
let's ignore all of them and just say
suppose you just or you do it justice
that's right so there are some strings
that you know the horrible function yes
right so we can discuss offline right
whether that's reason point everything
so suppose this is the problem we want
to solve right then we just do the
simple gradient you can be more you can
fancy arrogant to second-order
algorithm then that's the greater
algorithm that's what network Softworks
okay so what can we write okay so so so
this approach again expresses express an
address powerful solver and and you
react attractor changing conditions so
what can we say let me tell you a little
bit about Monte and then the tracking
performance its optimality are the
appropriate functions in the local
office is gradient algorithm so it's not
surprisingly you will even converge to
low quality and he was a finite then the
sequence itself will converge
just to standard gradient behavior so
I'm gonna certain assumption the local
recipe comes global so there's certain
assumption and then there's this
condition
in other ways next slide I'll comment on
whatever assumptions are reasonable what
the assumption is is the following so p0
v k's are certain uncontrollable verbals
so in a particular for those in power
this is the real party substation say we
don't control this so ace will all be
the intelligent loads that we control
for example this is the voltage
magnitude square at every node k so
those can control variables at the
function fix if this is convex and this
is concave so these are the assumptions
they look at the set a so X again is the
simple path constraint on the verbal
control over breaks and give that
constraint so so there's a voltage
constraint that become function of X so
the voltage type of bias is we we had
supposed to look at a smaller
combination of so this sum it's a take
if the comments are local optimum lies
in the set a then the local results
becomes global and therefore well we can
make a arbitrary close to the original
feasible set all these assumptions
reasonable there you can show okay so
you so a is not tiny is it is reasonable
otherwise it's not meaningful then are
these assumptions reasonable well it
turns out for each such function you can
write down a certain table here it's a
very simple form opf a is radio network
if SOC p for the OPF is exact then these
conditions are satisfied not again
there's no guarantee but our experience
many other people's experience is that
very often it is exact and therefore is
probably not entirely unreasonable
assumptions but of course there's no
guarantee that you will get global
optimal let's try to estimate the gap
between
these sub the any local optimal end it's
not quite comparing color bottom so it
stood so the savings are falling pick
any local optimal compared with any
feasible point they are slightly away
from the boundary now the global optimum
can happen to be at the boundary which
is not uncommon but compare these two
points so you look at the cost of any
local optimum the cause of any feasible
points slightly away from the boundary
you can bank them is a messy expression
but if you look at our to attest systems
and so on so forth this is to be very
small so what is suggest informally that
any local optimum is probably almost as
good as initially interfere interior
Facebook I'll show you some examples
where we're so that's the first part so
so we have some understanding of this
optimality properties the second is
tracking performance so so far we have
been looking at static opf so we have
this problem and you want to solve in
real time so that you you you
continuously compute the additions for
the controller devices you interact with
the network and you just and then we
know roughly as in tactically how you
might be you can do this computation or
some dynamically network conditions are
changing so the network condition
changing is one big reason but also
there are applications now these are
applications that we imagine right so
these are the future applications where
you probably have to do in a district
manager this just know where you can
collect information centrally solve rate
and Huy converges in
dispatch now of course the talk here
doesn't address those issues because
there's a big issue on what if not
everything is observable what if you
have to do in a destroyed man and all of
that but but but that's sort of I'm
lying on motivation for the first
motivations yeah five minutes
so the first motivations is tracking is
the following suppose our network
changes slowly it doesn't have to be
slowly I suppose never changes its
characterized by some parameter comment
that changes over time this could be low
changes or generations a renewable
generation that changes and so on and
therefore each time T you can opf as a
possible
every time you compute a gradient step
you apply then the network changes you
could you could look at the case where
the network changes the slower x times
that that you you compute n and you you
compute imply ten gradient stairs and
then a never changes let's say the
network changes the same speed as your
controls let's compare the performance
of the online algorithm applied here
with the optimal solution of here so
optimal solution here means that each
time T suppose you solve this optimally
and globally optimally something and
then look at the cost some over a
certain horizon so the global optimal is
this X star
I'm almost done
okay all right
okay so the global optimum is the X star
so given a global optimal X star
sequence vector u some movies cause
that's the optimal cost probably not
realizable and then suppose we just do
the naive first auto-graded every time T
you get a YT then problem changes but
your computer T plus one and then you
apply it again and so on right so then
you look at the cost and you can bound
them and you has two terms so the
structure is that you didn't net if the
OPF um doesn't drift where fast it's so
intuitive it's not surprisingly then the
bang is low right so the OPF doesn't
drift fast is that the optimal motion
from T to T plus 1 does not change much
and this term is small and this term has
to do with this great an algorithm just
local algorithm there's always potential
gap between the local optima and a
global optimum and therefore you if this
changes slower than square root T then
the per stab regret the divide both side
by by T then this term goes away and
therefore if the Ray of drifting is
small then the first area is as
interrobang bias over average local
average gap between local and global
optimal so I did probably no way to get
rid of this yes
maybe me / not appropriate normalized
probability we have a problem
so our business or some simulations so
this is this set of networks with
different sizes this is even software so
gives in this particular simulation is
it's radio networks the distribution
network is actually multi-phase
unbalanced but you can solve recession
you can check you get out more solution
so you can look at the optimal cost you
can look at the computational time in
CVX and then this is the student then
went on its own code just do these
gradients there this is a static static
problem static opf the objective
function and and the computational times
where business is his own consoles but
just get our of manner the error is the
difference between the objective value
so it sends you 0 and then the speed-up
is significant if the network is large
even though the gradient the online
algorithm achieve essentially the same
objective function the solutions are
actually quite it can be quite different
so immune studies is very flat
okay I will stop with the same message
thank you very much is there any chance
of you break in half of them being
decomposable in any way
yes so you can do it distributor manner
okay so the short answer is yes but I
think there's a lot of work that needs
to be done that we have not seriously
looked at for example this is a small
piece of chief thesis we're just
starting on this oh no yes in this
example we actually did a it's not only
the multi phase embarrassed a Tory
statue distributed algorithm but he's
this really design is is is this it's
not simple it's quite messy so I think
there are a lot of work that this still
needs to be time to have a nice clean
distributor do something that's be
composability schedule interior and then
i see that we haven't right don't know
as I can see in this simulation results
as the network become larger the speed
gets more faster generally the trend is
like this right the speed up or yes why
it is the reason
not clear it could be the guess one can
I guess one can look there whether these
scales at a faster rate and then this
but this is low cloud with them your
comparison of online solution to the
linear currency using Linnaean
optimization and compare their speed
because current rate is maybe even by I
think utility companies stick so they
are billion is the speed so well here
when you compare with comebacks selects
it's much difference right the speed
and when you come here to renew you can
see you become much more right right so
for this particular set of this is
actually one of the real networks in a
year and therefore we have done a lot in
for this but here said we did look at if
you solve the linear problem but not
using DCOP fd0 PFE is not suitable for
distributing systems but parang mousse
or each new model actually has a beam
europe so we do use that the result
shows that because for this particular
network they have is the loss is low is
sort of over built and therefore the
objective function between the
linearized and the parameters the
non-linear is small the computational
time this is this is significantly
higher than with the software we know
so you know they must must kill episode
of the libertarian fantasy they all have
solar panels on our roofs and you know
and basically can go off the grid and in
that in that Nirvana penny quotes
nobody there's nobody who's doing the
optimization your distributions are
right Nirvana's ridiculous of course
there will be some some
somebody what's this important
optimization problem
on a distribution side
so right okay I get a lot of discussion
but let me give you one example which is
the real example there's a start-up
really very very interesting startup
that uses Tesla battery packs to provide
a to services so they have two revenue
streams why is to reduce the demand
response for buildings one is that you
provide demand response for SCE
now what can you imagine that so that
they can in the future work with SE e to
jointly optimize not only their storage
but also some SS on the grid
distribution grid for example you could
imagine you have community solar stuff
that you can or a grenadiers that Trani
optimize there is great as and so on but
again all these are future scenarios but
especially this
daily basis how how variable almost
really well
when it depends on today in the future
potentially but just on a periodic side
let me show you real data to up do I
have it I think it depends probably
depends on applications one you might be
able to do it one may require much
faster timescale read a patient so how
so this is a set of the one one graph
for each day just look at the upper
graph so this is the e V charging this
is really charging a counter is it very
periodic someone but there's significant
variation now what is the Optima sitting
here is that if you optimize you can
user doing this you can squash it so the
P the lower the peter-patter and
therefore for this this assumes one
minute are updates
thank you thank you very much